it's been a whirlwind for our next guest
in recent days went from being the
quarterback's coach to the la rams in
super bowl 53 to the head coach of the
cincinnati bengals the next day he is
zach taylor coach how are you buddy
i'm doing great mike thanks for having
me on hey thanks for taking some time i
know it's been a busy time for you
getting settled in in cincinnati give me
an idea of of what it was like for you
when you go into your office in
cincinnati at the team facility close
the door sit down behind the desk for
the first time what do you do what do
you think how does it how does it all
hit you at that moment
well you take a deep breath first of all
um it certainly was an exciting time
you know personally you're a little bit
conflicted you know when you just you
lose the super bowl something you've
worked for for a long time and it was a
lifelong dream to get to that point and
then all of a sudden you got this major
life event that's occurring that you're
excited about as well so
you know we really got to hit the ground
running here because you know we were
the last hire so you know you just kind
of sit down at the desk you take a deep
breath and you try to take it one task
at a time but most importantly we've
hired some good people already that i
trust to do their job and and really
help me that way so uh we're making good
progress here
yeah and and how big of a challenge is
it to throw that staff together with the
scouting combine just a couple of weeks
away you've got free agency coming up
some decisions need to be made
what are your days like as you try to to
get everything in place that you need to
have in place
well you had a good idea of some people
you went on staff particularly on the
side of the ball that i'm accustomed to
working with and
so the most important thing is being
thorough and finding the right people i
think when you rush the process
you know and you get the wrong people
then the other stuff might not matter as
much so we're just being thorough uh
we're making sure we do a due process
and all the people that we interview and
find the right people in here and then
and then we'll get everything done you
know there might be some long hours once
we get it all in place but uh we got
plenty of time before week one starts
with the season and we'll get a chance
to evaluate all the players on this
roster and free agency and the guys in
the draft and we'll be prepared and
we'll be ready to make some good
decisions but i just want to make sure
that we're thorough and that we get the
right people in the building
you mentioned the side of the ball
you're familiar with obviously that's
the offense how involved will you be
defensively different coaches will will
have different approaches some delegate
the entire defense to the coordinator
others find a way to stay involved
what's your approach going to be i'd
like to be involved you know i think
that's one way you build a relationship
with the players is you understand what
what they're going through what they're
being taught what the scheme is what
it's asking them to do so that you can
hold those guys to a high standard and
so i'd like to be you know i'd like to
be aware of how we're doing everything
uh give my input as an offensive guy you
know anywhere i can help i think that's
always uh
helpful same thing with the defense
again helping with the offense i always
think it's good to get their opinion and
how they see things and things that give
them an issue so as long as there's good
dialogue and there's healthy
communication
then we'll all be on the same path
sometimes there are coaching candidates
in your age range mid mid 30s
coaches that haven't been full-time
coordinators the opportunity though
comes to be a head coach how did you
know that for you this was the right
time to make that move instead of maybe
waiting a year or two
well i think i've been part of some
great organizations with some good
people that have seen the lead um in
that role and
being being with sean the last two years
he's a young guy i got to see firsthand
all the things he went through the tough
times the good times and the way that he
did it and we're very much aligned at
how we think and how you want to build a
culture and so when you get to witness
that firsthand you got a head coach who
was so open with his communication and
wanted to help the other coaches um that
had aspirations to be a head coach it
was a very productive two years for me
we got a lot accomplished i learned a
lot and you felt like you were ready for
this role when it came
are you bringing the playbook that you
used in la with coach mcvay are you
going to have your own that you concoct
well it'll be the cincinnati bengals
playbook there's no question about it
the starting point will be what we did
in l.a we had a lot of success there i
believed in what we did um but i think
it was also important to hire people
with outside experiences brian callahan
had been in denver with peyton manning
for a long time detroit oakland
um alex van pelt has had a lot of
history as well as bob mcnell and jamal
singleton jim turner james all these
guys have different experiences and i
haven't worked with them aside from the
line coach so
it's good it's people i trust people i
heard great things about people that are
like-minded and want to do things the
way that we want them done
but i do think it is good to get people
with experiencers from outside of the
buildings i've been in uh to see a new
way of doing things and help this
offense evolve
and you're going to be calling the plays
correct
yes i will
will you be the guy talking to the
quarterback
yes i will yep
um yeah so you know we'll have input
from the whole staff but it'll certainly
be on the sidelines talking to the
quarterback on game day
will it be the same approach that sean
mcveigh has with jared goff to the point
where you know sometimes the quarterback
would like the coach to just be quiet
i think all options are on the table you
know and that's i look forward to former
relationship with andy and he's had a
lot of success in this league i'm
excited to work with him
um so you know there's certainly things
that we're still working through here as
a staff as we get the playbook in order
and kind of what our process is going to
be going forward as we as we build this
bengals offense
you know when we look at the
quarterbacks around the nfl zach there's
that small handful that we know are the
true franchise quarterbacks there's the
guys that we know just aren't getting it
done and then there's that gap of guys
in the middle and you i you know andy
dalton fairly falls somewhere in the
middle and some bengals fans would say
the ship has sailed we've seen what we
have it's time for someone new what do
you say to the bengals fans that would
try to argue that it's time to find a
new quarterback
i've watched amy andy closely for the
last eight years dating back to his
college days and throughout the nfl and
i was in the afc for a long time so we
had a lot of crossover too i've always
thought very highly of him i think he's
a great fit for what we're going to do
he's really smart he's accurate he can
get the ball out on time
so i think he's going to fit this
offense to a t and i'm excited to work
with him
you know with a lot of nfl teams there's
a gm in place who clearly is running the
show from a personnel standpoint other
teams the coaches running the show it's
never really been all that obvious how
things work in cincinnati there isn't a
general manager purse say how involved
will you be in personnel picking players
and deciding who gets contracts deciding
who gets drafted how much involvement
will you have right out of the gates
with that
well it's exciting because they want the
coaching staff to be very involved with
the whole scouting process and
i i love that and so we're gonna have
clear communication with myself duke
tobin his staff my staff
mr brown so we're all on the same page
we've had a lot of conversations about
all this we all feel we're very much
aligned you know i talk to those guys on
a daily basis to make sure that there's
clear communication throughout the
building on what our expectations are
of our coaching staff and as we go
forward selecting these players so
um i i really enjoy the process how it's
gone so far and look forward to as the
draft comes around letting this thing
continue to evolve
i gotta ask you one super bowl 53
question i know you haven't watched the
game yet you told peter king that
recently but there's one play i gotta
ask about can i ask you one question
about the super bowl
great go ahead
okay all right and and it's a play that
apparently was run twice it was the play
where brandon cooks runs the post and
robert woods runs the underneath route
the first time the throw was to woods
the second time that play was run and
obviously we know the outcome cooks was
wide open jared goff didn't see him in
time
uh and jason mccourty made a great play
on the ball who was the who was the
primary on that was it set up for cooks
to spring free and was that the guy who
was supposed to get the ball or was it
woods again doing the underneath route
well i would say that that
that play specifically i wouldn't say it
was run twice it may have appeared to be
run twice but it wasn't the exact same
play and
um you know all options are on the table
on that thing and sometimes the coverage
can change from what you're attacking um
so to be honest i'd like to go back and
watch that before i give you a full
answer but
um to my recollection i don't think we
ran the exact same play twice it may
appear to have been the same similar
plays but
um from what i remember those two plays
were a little bit different in terms of
the progressions
when do you think the world will slow
down enough for you to go back and watch
that game or when will you even want to
watch that game i remember dave
gettleman who was the gm of the panthers
at the time
refusing to watch super bowl 50. when
when will you find the time and make the
time to watch super bowl 53
well my priority right now is getting
this thing in order um
yeah of course mike there is value you
got to learn hard lessons sometimes from
some adversity that you face so i know
the importance of going back through and
making sure that that's a learning
experience for for the staff that we
have here
so there will be a time i can't pinpoint
when that will be that i'll go back
through and review it and and take any
lessons that you can take from it so
hopefully you know if the next super
bowl that we get a chance to participate
in we can learn from those lessons and
be the best thing that we could be
but i can't give you the exact date but
it'll be sometime in the near future
i don't know if you saw the comments
from brian hoyer the backup quarterback
in new england who played the role of
jared goff for the scout team but he he
was very candid with albert breer of
si.com that that he had watched all or
nothing when
sean mcvay had first shown up as head
coach some of the things he was saying
some of the things he'd seen publicly
and and i think it's caused some around
the league to say hey we need to
evaluate how much stuff we put out there
i don't know if you saw what hoyer had
to say but do you have concern that the
things that get put out there could be
used against you at some point down the
line maybe when you least expect it
well i think you always have to be
mindful of that i have not seen the
comments and to be honest i
you know my
i haven't even translated my phone or
the internet early in the last week and
so i've just been moving along here in
this building but i certainly do think
you have to be mindful of what you put
out there and the information you have
is is specific to the club that you're
with and you want to make sure that you
keep that uh within the building as best
you can and you know in this day and age
with the media there's a lot of
information that's out there and that's
just the way it is that's what the fans
want that's probably what the league
wants and i get all that i get that
there's that aspect of it at the same
time
um you know you got to be protective of
of your information that's going to help
you win on game day and anything that
gets out there that could hurt you
obviously you want to try to defend
against that and protect against that
it really is amazing to think what you
and and likewise brian flores the new
coach of the dolphins have gone through
the last two weeks i mean two weeks ago
you were five days away from coaching in
the super bowl and then boom right after
that you're a head coach of a team super
bowl weekend and i know the rules are
fuzzy about what can and can't be said
but saturday sunday of the super bowl
like what did you know about what was
going to happen to you on monday
you know i had a sense i i i tried to
pin it off
because i wanted my focus just to be on
on helping us when i didn't think it was
fair to anybody else to focus on
otherwise but um you don't get the sense
that monday you'll get a chance to go
back to cincinnati on tuesday
get this press conference underway but
again one thing i appreciate about the
bengals and the way that they went about
it was they really let me be in la ram
for up to the last second and they
really didn't bother me we trusted each
other that this process was going to
finish out the right way and i think
that was one of the reasons we hit it
off in our first interview was there was
that trust there and there was that open
communication
and so they really did an outstanding
job and i know that they appreciate the
rams um the way that they handled it as
well and we just we had minimal contact
and got through the super bowl and then
hit the ground running when monday came
around
hey one last question for you before i
let you get back to work you know
bengals fans they were spoiled by five
straight years of playoff appearances
although disappointed by no playoff wins
has been kind of a malaise around the
team the past few years what do you say
to win those fans over fill up the
stadium get people engaged in the
bengals moving forward
well i don't want to make any bold
predictions but what i can tell them is
that we're going to build this culture
here in this building one day at a time
it's by having the right people that are
around our players having the right
players in the building and setting high
standards for these guys and it'll be
it'll be clear from day one when they
walk in the building so now we certainly
feel like our schemes are going to be
very sound and
uh creative and you know so we're going
to push the envelope in that regard um i
think by the first time that it rolls
around i think these fans will fill
these seats and be excited to see what
we can put on the field because we'll be
prepared we'll be ready and it'll be an
exciting time for all of us
exciting times and busy times coach i
know things don't slow down for you
until the middle of june at the earliest
we wish you all the best as you make the
transition congratulations on your
success look forward to seeing you at
the combine and talking to you soon
you bet mike thanks for having me on
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports